Jodie Foster bonjour merci d'être là je
suis ravie d'échanger avec vous et bravo
oui j'ai amené la palme d'or pour vous
montrer que c'était pas tous une blague
vous avez ressenti quoi quand thierry
Frémont vous a appelé pour vous dire que
vous allez recevoir une palme ordonneur
c'est très émouvant vraiment parce que
j'ai commencé ma carrière ici avec Taxi
Driver quand j'avais 13 ans enfin
j'avais déjà fait des films mais c'était
le début de quelque chose de film
significative de films d'auteur j'ai dit
Foster quel est votre rôle exact dans
Taxi Driver oh je sais pas comment on
dit en français
moi j'ai des autres amours que j'ai
entendu à l'école mais je peux pas lui
dire voilà on ne les dira pas de revenir
comme ça après tant d'années c'est
quelque chose vous êtes venu souvent à
Cannes mais c'est vrai que cette montée
des marches pour Taxi Driver si vous
fermez les yeux et que vous partez en
arrière vous vous voyez quoi vous
ressentez quoi je sais pas c'était
c'était comme un comment dire aller à
Disneyland c'était tout farfeluche
j'étais un peu angoissée un peu nerveuse
mais excité 13 ans aussi il y avait
peut-être beaucoup d'insouciances à
l'époque on se rend moins compte des
choses j'avais pas mal de confiance
quand j'avais pas pourquoi mais j'avais
pas mal de confiance j'étais venue ici
avec ma mère il y avait de Niro et ce
qu'en 16 qui était un peu cap d'anti
parce qu'ils avaient peur le film avait
été jugé un petit peu pour la violence
et comme c'était moi qui parlait
français c'était moi qui défendait le
film devant tout le monde alors c'était
inattendu et vraiment un souvenir que je
garderai pour toujours on a l'impression
vous avez jamais eu peur de rien que
vous avez toujours été très très forte
et obligé d'être forte aussi tout au
long de votre carrière
je sais pas je sais pas si je sais pas
c'est peut-être un instinct de survie
alors c'est peut-être une mauvaise chose
en fait mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
beaucoup peur de des choses vis-à-vis du
caméra etc mais
j'ai peur par exemple des des computers
quand je disais être forte c'est aussi
vous êtes battu par exemple pour les
rôles qui vous ont apporté vos deux
Oscars les accuser le sciences des
anneaux quels souvenirs vous vous gardez
de ces combats que vous avez mené pour
pour y arriver c'est normal quand on
sait qu'il y a un rôle qui pour vous on
sait que ce rôle vous le comprenez au
fond de votre cœur et vous ne savez même
pas les raisons sont un peu inconscients
il faut se battre
ils étaient ils étaient pour vous est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
ouvert la voie pour pour toutes les
autres générations Jennifer Lawrence
Christian Stewart par exemple vous cite
souvent en exemple ça me touche vraiment
de les voir grandir de les voir parce
que j'ai connu quand j'étais très jeune
et de les voir mûrir de voir leur jeu de
voir le travail qui font et aussi le
pouvoir qui prennent pour eux-mêmes
cette prochaine génération je suis très
fière parce que bon moi je viens d'une
différente d'une génération il y avait
des choses qui n'étaient pas possible
pour moi et il y a aussi des poids que
je que je bagage des valises que je
traîne avec moi qui ont avoir mémère et
mes grands-mères c'est et ça ferait
vraiment du bien de voir ces jeunes
femmes s'ouvrir au futur votre mère qui
était assez pessimiste sur l'avenir des
l'avenir pour une femme dans le cinéma
elle me disait toujours bah c'est bien
d'être pessimiste parce que comme ça on
n'est jamais déçu
vous est-ce que justement il y a un
exemple que vous avez suivi tout au long
de votre carrière
l'exemple ça vient du Spike Lee enfin
c'est dureating je dis toujours ça à mes
enfants c'est le moment que vous suivez
une moralité que ça soit dans le choix
de rôle le choix de cinéma que ça soit
dans dans Comment vous traitez les gens
comment vous êtes en business ça amène
au plaisir ça mène
comment on dit mais aussi je pense que
c'est toujours la bonne voie justement
vous parlez de satisfaction de moralité
on sent que vraiment vous êtes une
actrice une réalisatrice qui qui fait
des choix
il y a des périodes où vous avez moins
tournées vous tournez vous tournez moins
c'est très important pour vous que
chaque film est une vraie place
pour tourner ça fait partie de ma
personnalité c'est je suis trifoalisée
et quand je fais quelque chose je le
fais à fond et j'ai envie que ça soit le
meilleur c'est un peu perfectionniste
mais aussi
j'aime bien faire des choses d'une façon
très profonde et puis après
me marrer après les vacances
alors je suis j'ai deux modes comment on
dit pour moi le cinéma c'est c'est
génial parce qu'on arrive à faire un
film pendant un an ou deux ans même
trois ans en tant que mettait en scène
et puis après vous avez deux ans de pour
penser pour vivre pour voir qu'est-ce
qui vous passionne
alors vous parlez très bien très bien
notre langue c'est un vrai plaisir vous
avez une passion pour la France et la
France a une passion pour pour vous
comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette
relation avec la France Les Français ils
aiment bien leur langue c'est tout c'est
la seule raison ils aiment bien leur
langue et moi aussi et c'est une chose
que j'apprécie beaucoup les mots moi
j'ai été un lycée français quand j'avais
commencé à l'âge de 9 ans pour apprendre
le français et les autres langues aussi
l'italien espagnol et pour moi la langue
c'est la communication ce contact avec
des gens c'est
ça fait partie de ma personnalité de
vouloir collecter de cette façon là et
je pense que les Français normalement
ils sont élevés un petit peu comme ça
aussi et vous n'êtes pas que spectatrice
de films français vous avez joué un rôle
majeur par exemple dans la carrière de
la Haine de Mathieu Kassovitz qui est né
à Cannes je crois que vous êtes fier
d'ailleurs d'avoir fait en sorte que le
film sorte aux États-Unis quand vous
dites né à Cannes parce que j'ai entendu
ça avec Tahar aussi je dis mais tenez à
Cannes toi il y a des maisons c'est une
expression que je connaissais pas avant
avant hier soir
non c'était une pour moi moi je dis
toujours quand on me demande quel est
votre film dont vous êtes depuis fier
j'ai toujours la haine pourtant j'avais
rien à faire avec la haine j'ai juste
aidé à le distribuer aux États-Unis
pourquoi parce que c'était bon voilà
c'est la seule raison c'est un film
merveilleux à qui m'a touché qui a
touché énormément de gens bien sûr qui a
changé une vision de la France
parce que je pense que le monde avait
une fausse vision de la France que le
France était figé que ça n'allait jamais
changé que c'était la transformation et
c'est pas possible et qui connaissait
pas le sens diverses les les
nationalités diverses qui font partie de
la de l'expérience française pour
conclure je dis qu'est-ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui de votre statut de
star
je suis pas l'impression enfin je sais
pas vous savez aux États-Unis on dit
toujours
et c'est vrai que je travaille très peu
je travaille de temps en temps quand je
vois un film que absolument qu'il faut
que je fasse je travaille beaucoup plus
en tant que scène et pour moi être star
je sais pas je me vois pas tellement ça
mais ça m'a donné la possibilité de
faire autre chose dans le cinéma et de
faire passer des messages forts et
défendre vos combats vous convient merci
beaucoup de Jodie merci d'avoir un vrai
plaisir OK